welcome back to my round five game from
the fuj blitz tournament in this one I'm
playing Grandmaster Walter Arabia
Rodriguez from Cuba and he's actually a
former World Junior Champion uh he won
the world junior Championship in 1986 so
we we sit down we shake hands and then
immediately we have some clock trouble
neither of us can seem to figure out how
to start the clock
[Music]
Lo
and yeah sometimes chess clocks can be
confusing there's a lot of different
models all of them have like different
types of buns the Arbiter does some
magic trick presses a bunch of buns and
then finally we get
going and we start the game so Pawn
E4 and I decided to play a
sicilian and just settling in here and
he goes into an open Sicilian and I'm
playing one of my favorite variations
within the Sicilian Defense this is the
tonov and he looks away for a moment
deciding what to
do ends up going for Knight C3 and
Bishop E3 and then a very trendy line
Queen to F3 now I'm prepared for this I
play Knight to
F6 and very soon I mean this line has a
tendency of getting very very sharp uh
cuz White's idea is to quickly Castle
Queens side and and then build up a lot
of pressure uh in the center and
eventually on the king side so he does
Castle I play Knight
E5 and this is still preparation for
me I'm attacking the Queen centralizing
the knights he plays Queen G3 I play
Pawn B5 still
theory he plays Pawn F4 and here I
hesitate because I had a almost brief
lapse of my memory I was trying to
remember between Knight G6 or Knight G4
uh which move to play I realize if I
play Knight G6 E5 and my knight can't
get to G4 so yeah I take a moment I play
the correct theoretical move Knight E to
G4 and now I'm immediately hitting the
bishop on
E3 and I'm still in preparation even
though I took a moment there to remember
uh he goes for E5 here and I very
quickly take the bishop and after he
takes back I play Pawn to before and
this is a really nice counterattacking
move and it's still within opening
preparation on my part uh I've had this
a few times in online games uh it's been
a while since I had this exact position
but there was a time about 3 years ago I
had this opening twice in the same week
and I made a couple YouTube videos about
it uh once was against Christopher Yu
who I don't think was a grandmas at the
time and then I had another game in the
same position a day or two later so I
was really happy to get this position
against my opponent even though this is
not a line I've reviewed recently the
idea for black is I'm counterattacking
the Knight on C3 and if Knight E4 I'm
happy to trade and then get a position
where it's relatively open and I have
the bishop pair and if white takes my
knight on F6 then I would take back and
black is already for choice in such a
position so he takes a lot of time here
trying to figure out what option to go
with if he should move the Knight or
take my knight and then he finally plays
Knight to E4 so offering the trade of
knights in a slightly different way
avoiding the complications with the
pawns
capturing and I pretty quickly take on
e4 he takes back with queen and I play
Bishop to B7 at this point I'm feeling
very good was pretty much an opening
success develop the light squ Bishop
with Tempo have the really nice long
diagonal and he has to figure out what
to do with his Queen so he hesitated
there for a brief moment and then plays
Queen to
E1 yeah it's a slightly passive move
Queen E1 one idea is maybe to eventually
transfer the queen to the king side but
I'm feeling very good I play Bishop to
C5
developing actively and my plan in the
position is very simple I just want to
Castle King side connect my Rooks and
then as quickly as possible start
storming my pawns on the queen side
really want to get this move in A5 and
A4 he starts with Knight B3 attack my
Bishop I move back to E7 and he plays
Bishop to D3 now when I had played
Bishop C5 I was kind of anticipating
this knight move and I thought that even
though it looks like I wasted time
moving my Bishop to C5 and then back I
can use this Knight on B3 as fuel for my
Pawn storm and here uh yeah I go for
Pawn A5 which just prepares to play Pawn
A4 hitting the Knight with Tempo and my
eventual dream is to pawn storm far
enough where I can open up files on the
queen side and get to the the white king
so he plays Bishop to E4 uh trying to
simplify a bit offering the trade the
Bishops and this is probably a logical
move because it's hard for me to avoid
the bishop trade and usually trades will
favor the side who is getting attacked
because then it can be harder to uh to
keep the attack going so I'm trying to
figure out what to do here with the the
bishop tension I could take but I start
with Pawn to A4 attacking the
knights he plays Knight to
D4 and again I take a bit of time here
cuz there are a handful of options for
me I could take the bishop on e4 but I
was also considering B3 or A3 to just
try and induce some weaknesses in white
structure ultimately I decide to Castle
King
side and uh then he very quickly takes
on B7 I
recapture and then he plays King to B1
so trying to just weather the storm on
the The Queen's side but I'm happy that
I got in cing King side because now my
other Rook can be ready to join the
party and here I'm still deciding what
move I want to start with I could go for
A3 to try and attack the dark squares
but the issue with A3 is after B3 it's
hard for me to get my darks were Bishop
into play so I end up going for B3 which
combines a lot better with my darks for
Bishop because my pawns are light
squares the diagonal for the bishop
opens up and it's pretty much impossible
here for white to prevent the files from
opening inevitably there are going to be
some trades of Pawns and with Pawn B3
this is basically a pawn sacrifice so he
takes on
B3 I take back then he takes with Knight
so he won two pawns I won one Pawn I'm
now down upon PA but I have the two half
open files on the queen side to work
with these a and b files are very nice
for my queen and hopefully both Rooks to
access and this is another moment where
I'm taking time because the move I
really wanted to play here was Rook
takes A2 uh to sacrifice the rook and
after King takes play Rook A8 check but
um it was a difficult line to calculate
because after King B1 white takes wasn't
sure if I have enough compensation for
sacking material so there are other
options for black to consider here I was
looking at Queen A6 or queen A7 creating
a battery also bringing my kingside rook
in to C8 or B8 and uh it's one of these
positions where I know I should be
better but I'm kind of spoiled for
choice and I have to find some kind of
plan or just go for the media tactics so
at this point I've actually already
fallen lower on time than my opponent
but I figured it is a critical moment
makes sense for me to try and play the
best move here and eventually I play
Rook F to B8 which actually turned out
to be a mistake even though I was just
trying to improve my worst place piece
in the position uh there were some
better options for me which I can show
in is after this game and he plays this
move Queen to
E2 which turns out to be a very bad
mistake and in this position I have one
single move to achieve a winning
position and I was smelling blood here
and the move I was fixated on was Rook
takes
A2 which uh of course was on my mind the
previous move and I was trying to
calculate what happens after King takes
A2 and then Queen takes B3 and then the
King goes back to B1 and can I generate
enough play like Bishop A3 there's Rook
D2 I was also looking at branches where
I throw in Rook a check and I ended up
burning a lot of time here not arriving
at a definite
conclusion and the more time that passed
the less sure that I was about
sacrificing The Rook so I end up playing
a safer move Queen A7 but we can see by
the eval bar this kind of gave away my
whole Advantage gives white time to
defend with Knight
C1 I play Bishop A3 trying to throw the
whole kitchen sink at my opponent but he
plays Rook D2 and even though I have all
my pieces in Prime attacking position on
the queen side it's really hard to crack
white setup B2 and A2 are well defended
I start start with Rook B7 here to try
and double up Rooks on the B file but he
was pretty unfaced he plays Rook HD1
attacking my Pawn on
D7 now D7 is defended so um I'm not too
concerned about that just yet I Del up
my Rooks on the B file he plays Knight
B3 I play Bishop to B4 and he's still
maintaining uh decent control on the
queen side uh with Bishop B4 I'm saving
my Bishop attacking The Rook on
D2 and he plays Rook to
C2 I shuffle back my Rook to
eight attacking
A2 and he returns his Knight to C1 so
it's actually a really frustrating
position because I keep trying to poke
and prod but white is still very solid
and keep in mind I'm still down a pawn
and it's not clear what attack I
actually have in the position so I'm
really just looking for ways to keep the
pressure I play Queen A4 here which
looks like an aggressive move but I'm
not actually sure what it does uh just
trying to optimize a queen he
centralizes his Queen I drop back to B5
defending my Rook on
B7 then he hesitates here he was about
to move his Rook from D1 but then he
starts thinking again and decides to
move his Queen to see C4 offering the
queen trade and here I definitely don't
want to trade Queens I really want to
keep any chances of attack alive I Dro
My Queen back to
B6 and yeah we're in a position where
it's kind of hard for either side to
make
progress he was about to move his Rook
there but takes his hand back and thinks
some
more but Meanwhile we're both very low
on time both below 20 seconds he plays
Queen E4 centralizing the queen
again I play Rook a B8 tripling up on
the B file he plays Knight to B3 useful
Square to neutralize the B file I move
my Rook back to the a file he plays
Queen D4 I avoid the queen trade with
Queen A6 and he plays Knight C1
defending
A2 and I plays this move H6 making some
error for my king he plays Rook at D3
very useful move preparing Rook to B3 to
try and exploit my Bishop on
B4 and I play Rook B7 he plays Rook B3 I
play Queen to F1 uh finally intruding
White's position and then he plays Queen
to C4 and I touch my Bishop not
realizing my queen was attacked it was
touch move oh no my queen and at this
point I realize I'm just dead I resign
the game ends super abruptly in what was
a kind of disappointing finish
especially given the fact I had a great
opening great middle game attacking
potential but uh yeah this is the nature
of Blitz this is also the nature of over
theboard Blitz where if you touch a
piece you have to move it I usually
don't make such mistakes especially this
was just a simple queen move attacking
my queen but sometimes in chess it can
be easy to overlook these things
especially with low time on the clock so
let's do analyze some of the key moments
of this game there is a lot to unpack
and starting with opening um it's always
nice to get a bunch of prep from early
on and he actually was asking me after
the game like what the theory is in this
line and I was explaining to him that in
this position it's not good for white to
play E5 uh White should move the Bishop
from E3 the two main moves are Bishop D2
or Bishop to G1 but uh it's
understandable that he went for E5 not
knowing the theory because this line
would be good for white if black doesn't
have B4 but thankfully yeah I played B4
and I think I first saw this idea maybe
four years ago a good friend of mine Uh
Kevin go from Singapore was a victim of
this line from the white side I remember
him sharing his game with me and then I
got inspired to kind of add this to my
time on of preparation so the position
is already preferable for black and the
two online games I've had in this
previously my opponents have taken and
this would have been a sharper line
after takes and then takes and then
takes and then King B1 and then takes uh
gets really messy where black has a Pawn
on B2 uh but Black's in very good shape
here with the bishop hair and more
attacking potential uh against White's
King so yeah he played Knight E4 and I
was very very comfortable here now I
want to zoom forward to the key tactical
moment cuz the position basically played
itself up until this point and this was
the first critical moment where the
engine did not like my move Rook fb8
even though it looked very natural uh
what I could have done here it was
started with Queen A7 and after Knight
to C1 the engine really likes the idea
of putting the Rook on C8 and then
pretty much regardless of what white
does the plan is to sacrifice The Rook
for the Knight and then take on A2 and
supposedly there's just overwhelming
compensation for black uh in this
position so I made a small misjudgment
putting my Rook on B8 but then after
Queen E2 this was my biggest missed
opportunity of the game cuz I had
identified the right move Rook takes A2
but I didn't pull the trigger and this
is one of these moves which I could have
played
intuitively understanding that after
takes takes takes White's King is just
uh getting really really unsafe and one
idea would be after King B1 I can simply
play Rook A8 Queen A2 is Unstoppable and
this would have been um a really really
nice position engine says Black's
completely winning here but uh yeah in
the game uh especially with time trouble
I did not quite make the right decision
going into this line and uh yeah after I
played Queen A7 I just didn't have such
an opportunity for the rest of the game
and after a lot of dancing uh my
opponent just bended off any sort of
pressure really well and uh yeah the
game ended really tragically missing the
fact that his Queen can move backwards
um to be fair though I was already in a
bit of trouble of course I should have
avoided the queen trade and saved my
queen here uh like Queen G1 probably was
best but uh yeah I don't really have
much attack here like can play G3
keeping all the pawns defended and yeah
there's still pressure against my bishop
and white would be in full control so
somewhat disappointing game in round
five but definitely some lessons to take
away hope you guys enjoyed this one if
you have questions leave them below if
you like the content subscribe do
appreciate it and stay tuned for the
next one see you guys soon